the next talk in this session so
it's my great pleasure to introduce
nikolai bjorner
who is a senior principal researcher at
microsoft research redmond
uh nicola is one of the lead authors of
the state-of-the-art
smt solver z3 which
uh has really has a revolutionary impact
in broad areas in software engineering
and security
c3 was developed jointly with leonardo
damora
uh and uh krista wintersteiger and i
believe more recently love
that manson uh for his work nikolai has
won
many awards so along with leonardo he
received the
her brown award at uh
also i believe he received a pldi award
uh i forget the exact was it the kind of
the impact award uh
nikolai at pldi let's let's skip
okay skip all that and uh
thank you again nikolai and uh he's
going to give us a talk about z3 thank
you nicholas
thank you all right so um in
continuation of the
bootcamp bootcamp talks
um i prepared a a hopefully gentle
introduction to smt
and since i developed an s t solver some
of the material is
in based on on using se3
but it aims to be of general uh
purpose interest and uh it won't
go into too much technical detail uh but
we can take such in maybe in
conversations
um so the structure of of this
uh talk is first i will go through smt
through the lens of cdl uh cdcl
um over theories and that
connects both to armaments
and and jakobs and sam's
renditions of cdcl
so it builds over those and
now in extension to the pseudo-boolean
solvers presented yesterday
i will go through a number of
smt solvers and
first for finer domains than various
base theories and reducible theories
uh i will explain what i mean by these
uh
and this is basically a taxonomy of how
you can
view different uh versions of s t
solvers i'll finish off with some sneak
peek on
building solvers on on top of s and t
so so
again the lens is viewing smt solving as
extensions
of set
now what is smt in a nutshell
the the question is you're giving a
logical formula say a first order
logical formula
uh typically we can assume that it for
starters that it's quantifier free
but but that's not a there's nothing
that that requires whether you are
quantifiers or not
and the the query is whether the formula
is satisfiable model or some
background theory and the smt solvers
have specialized algorithms for those
background theories so here's an example
smt formula it combines
three different theories first of all it
contains arithmetical symbols so it says
that if
x plus two equals y then as the
equation on the right hand side of the
implication holds
and the second of all it contains
interpreted functions select and store
from the array theory
and two of the relevant axioms
that define the behavior of select and
store
are given below so if you select at an
index
that you just stored at in the map you
get the value
you re-retrieve the value otherwise if
you select
a different key then you are retrieving
values in the store
prior to the latest updates
finally there's an uninterpreted
function
tagged onto the formula so this this
formula is valid as can be proved
given that x y minus x plus 2 is
is going to be the same as 3.
sorry y minus x plus 1 is going to be
the same with 3.
so one way of viewing smt solvers in the
landscape
of sisters brothers and cousins
is uh it
aims to bring expressitivity and the
ability to
express uh domain
domains seen typically in software
development
at their uh level abstraction level that
you find there
but then employs and steals and borrows
techniques
developed in the sad mib and csp
communities
so noteworthy with their sat solvers is
their
ability and their tuning to perform
cheap local inferences and then
garbage collect useless clauses
and the the um the strong heuristics and
methodologies for
for performing such inferences
is is our retained in the c as
snt world on the other hand when we
solve uh arithmetical formulas
uh the the inference mechanisms are
i borrow from mip technology so we apply
linear programming and branch and bound
and cuts
finally the the csp world
has perfected the art of global
propagators
and similarly in the s t
solvers we apply global property gators
when they are
cheap and narrow the search space
so in in in highlights uh
an smt solver can be viewed as
engine can be viewed as the set
component that does
case analysis and then theory solvers
that perform
theory reasoning so the
basic idea of such an integration can be
illustrated
here with a formula where you have three
clauses
ax is greater than or equal to zero and
y equals
x plus one and then you have a
disjunction that sets bounds at y
uh the the sat solver will see a
propositional abstraction of this
formula
so the propositional abstractions are
these propositional variables p1 to p4
and the set solver can then solve such
a formula at the given
that it knows about propositional logic
it may find a
possible assignment that says
p1 2 and 4 to true and p4 3 to false
from the point of view of the theory
solver
it can consume a such an assignment
and in this version it
it then has a conjunction of linear
equalities and inequalities and it can
then decide
satisfiability of such a conjunction now
this conjunction is unsatisfiable
and the unsatisfiable core
is is really a combination of only three
of the four
propositional assignments so
so we take the the unsatisfiable core of
the
uh part the assignment and uh
expose as a new limit to the
sat solver that
then can work with it so the the
unsatisfied
core is also known as a theory conflict
so now programmatically uh
here's a view of a sat solver
the main elements of a set solver so
it runs in the in the catechol loop
um it it um
it incrementally checks uh whether you
have inferred the empty clause
and then the the state is unsatisfiable
if the state is currently in the
conflict
it performs limit learning and
backtracking
and back jumping if all variables
assigned
the state of the solver is satisfiable
otherwise if it is able to do
unit propagation it performs unit
propagation
and then it has a state where it can do
one of several possible things simplify
the global state
perform a restart prune
garbage collect or otherwise perform a
new decision
now what
when we add theory solvers uh we can
do this in a fairly
uh incremental fashion on top of the
ctcl loop
so the the main new additions for the
at adding a theory solver to set um
comprises of making uh
assignments and propagations theory
aware
so the main the first thing to notice is
on the bottom
so when we choose a new variable
uh assignment to a boolean variable
it we inform the theory solver
about this assignment we can also ask
the
theory solver to form perform unit
propagation
uh it can even simplify formula
participate in garbage collection
and and there's a new
twist in the final case where you don't
have any
assignments it's the cost of propagation
is not
uniformly as cheap as you see in
propositional satisfiability
so it makes sense to stage propagation
in when you integrate theories
so the main interfaces that a theory
solver then
should expose is essentially a set of
say call these callbacks that were in
red in the previous
slide and together with one i didn't
show which was
participating in the conflict analysis
step so as
when when a um that's the last line so
when this
theory solver assigns a boolean variable
by propagation it it also um
accumulates an explanation for this uh
assignment um
so here's a different view of uh the
same
sat loop as cdcl
and it gives a different way of showing
how
theory solvers are can be layered on top
of set solving
so in this view it's it's a set as a
rewrite system
there are two kinds of states you have
on the first line the initial state you
have an empty set of
assignments so an empty model and a
formula f
and then you can take one of
several possible different transitions
you can
augment the partial assignment using a
decision
so picking an unassigned literal and
then
add it to the decision stack perform
unit propagation
um or um
then if if all variables are signed
you know that that the formula is is
true
if you didn't get a conflict and now the
second
kind of state is when you have a
conflicting clause so a clause that's
false under the current assignment
and in this case the cd sales solver
engages in the dual
role of building a partial proof so
instead of building a partial model it
builds a partial proof
so now the the the the new thing with
respect to theory solvers is what
does uh how does this loop look in
context of theories
so first of all propagation if
theories may decide that or realize
that some unassigned literal uh
has a is forced by the current partial
assignment
so it can participate in in propagation
uh so there's these propagations are not
justified by the clauses
but they're justified by some theory
reasoning
a conflicting state as we saw in the
running example
can be a subset of the partial
assignment
that's false under the theory so in the
running
sample we had p1 p2 and p4 the
conjunction of those
literals was unsatisfiable so now that's
the
unsatisfiable state and and then
the the solver engages in a way of of
resolving
so finding a new back jumping point
conflict resolution itself or conflict
analysis
which is also known as uh also has
a a theory um version and this was
illustrated in depth
uh during uh jacob's talk on
pseudo-boolean formulas and there are
several analogies for other theories
so finally you can
augment the decision phase with
um having the theory solver
give hints of which literals to pick for
the the next decisions and what polarity
to assign them to
and um and as i said earlier
the the resolution phases was
illustrated
well in the context of pseudo-booleans
the the main questions now when you have
multiple theory solvers is then
how you can combine them so
first of all these questions are when
you have two
theories is the union of those theories
consistent
and then mechanically how to implement
it how do you create a solver
as a given that you have solvers for two
theory one and two how do you create a
solver for the combination
uh so just just to
illustrate what what i mean by multiple
theories so the
the blue red and green symbols come from
three different theories
and we're aiming to to create solvers
for the combinations of these theories
the main theorem uh that
smt solvers are essentially built on is
the nielsen artem theorem
and it states that the the union of
too uh consistent so so as
satisfiable sets of formulas
from two different theories assuming
that they
don't share any uh interpreted symbols
and that their models can be extended
with fresh elements without breaking
consistency the union of those theories
will be consistent
and the main
reason here is that you can create a
homomorphism from
from between these two two models
to to create a new model there are
several generalizations that have been
developed uh and and you can view this
nelson arben theorem as a special case
of
robinson amalgamation um
and and um there you you generalize
the the point of having a shared
theory being just the theory of equality
to being able to have theories that
share more than just equality
so now
the in terms of mechanizing
the combination of theories from a
solver point of view the main
ingredients
theory solvers use for
interacting on equalities is to be
receive states of what
terms are equal in the given
state or and optionally you can also
they can also act on which terms are
known to be distinct in a given state
and then for conflict resolution
they then also expose a method for
explaining why they propagated certain
equality so
so the theories may be able to not only
propagate
literals but also equalities between
themselves
but when once they propagate inequality
they're required also to retrieve
explanations when you perform a conflict
analysis
so that's the delta on top of
propositional
satisfiability
conflict analysis now um
in when theories uh
are convex meaning that they
when they apply when they imply some
disjunction of equalities they already
imply
one of the disjunctions then you can
typically do efficient equality
combination by rewriting into normal
forms now that's not always possible
not all theories are convicts for
example integer arithmetic is not convex
so what one can do instead is to
propagate equalities or share equalities
but apply various filters on those so
one
main filter that we use is to share only
equalities
that were used to show that a given
theory is consistent
so so in a nutshell we extract a model
a candidate model for a theory i
say the theory of arithmetic and in
if in that model two variables two
shared variables are
equal then we communicate we share that
equality
otherwise we are we don't need to agree
whether
those two variables are equal or
distinct
and there are various other stronger
filters one can
develop to to minimize the
uh the communication of equalities
and then finally for
theories where you don't have signature
disjoint
um there are
ways of combining
satisfiability as well
now um this is in the second part i will
go through
theories and and solvers and i'll follow
this
taxonomy of boolean base reducible
hybrid and external theories
so for the boolean finite domain
theories the main
exemplars are bit vector theories so
here's an example of a bit vector
formula
that encodes the apps
the absolute value operator
using bit masking
techniques and we can prove that the
absolute absolute
value operator is
is implemented by this masking technique
by proving an identity over bit vectors
the pseudo boolean formulas is another
class of boolean constraints uh finite
domains where you have enumeration types
uh again our finite domain
and and the the
previous talk introduced xors as
a boolean finite domain theory where the
operator xor had a special
decision procedure as well
the two main base theories that are used
are arithmetic and uninterpreted
functions
and in a nutshell all other theories
reduce
into those base theories so they either
reduce to arithmetic
uninterpreted functions or they are
finite domains and then handled by sat
so here's an example of an arithmetical
formula
you have x greater than or equal to zero
and then two
other clauses uh with inequalities over
x and y
and and where x and y range over wheels
and you can then uh solve and find
solutions to those
formulas an example of uninterpreted
function
formula is where you have a
and a sort s you we don't say
what what are the size of the how many
elements the domain of
s has so it may have one element two
elements or
arbitrary number of elements so that's
part of what we solve for here
and then the uninterpreted function f is
a unary
from s to s and we there's a consonant x
so in the the first constraint
uh has a solution um where
f is identity function and the
and it turns out that's the only
possible solutions because if we
solve for the second line where f is not
the identity function
uh that becomes unsatisfiable and then
i'll go through the solving methods for
for this theory
now other theories are as i said
can be reduced to this base theory and
a prolific example is theory of arrays
that was used in the introductory
example
so here's the example array formula and
in a nutshell what we do with array
formulas is to compile them
into by adding axioms from the theory of
arrays
until and this is the scary looking
possible augmentation of of this
the previous formula with added axioms
so first of all you you essentially
expand the select store axioms
by saturating with respect to them
and um and then for extensional arrays
where
you encode you enforce whether
two arrays are equal but if you don't
know if they have the same number
uh the selects are equal there you can
also expand that by introducing
a scolum term for the the quality
between arrays
called here here's called diff but the
main point here is that
several theories are essentially
reducible to the base theories
then there are hybrid theories that
combine
uh non-disjoint theories and a
important example here is the theory of
strings and sequences
uh in in this example we have
three strings st and u and it says that
if s
is a prefix of t and u is a suffix of t
but the lengths of s and u equals the
length of t
then indeed t has to be the
concatenation of s
with you and finally
a very important example of hybrid
theories quantifiers
finally constrains this code
is um i think a learning from
the the csp world is that uh
we in the s t we can encode theories
with the signatures
uh but it only goes as far as
the these theories allow succinct
encoding of
the kinds of constraints you are working
with
so in in this example uh with the
comprehension of sums we can write a
constraints
that when expanded into atomic formulas
becomes impractical to handle
and but there's nothing that prevents
snt solvers to contain
ad hoc theories by using
the same callbacks for propagation and
conflict
analysis as used by the general purpose
theories
so so here's an example that illustrates
a code snippet that
encodes the the cons the cardinality
constraint
uh very uh directly um
and and and this can be useful in in
combinatorial settings
so now i'll go over selected solvers for
these
uh theories uh and in
in one basic example we'll go through a
solver that combines
reasoning about finite domains
uninterpreted functions
and it indeed reduces to these base
theories
so the solver is uh for a
theory of unicode characters so the
domain of unicode is a finite domain
it has almost 200 000 elements
and it has all theories have the
equality relation but unicode also has
a less than or equal to relation
so the empirical observation is that the
less than or equal to relation
is is used uh
fairly rarely and the the main
operations that's used between
characters is just equality
so this suggests that a engine that's
based on union find for equality
plus a lazy reduction to with some
theory that
can handle inequality is um
has a is an advantage so for handling
inequalities
there's different choices of ways you
can embed
two inequalities you could use
arithmetic or or bit vectors and it
turns out the bit vector reduction
uh remains superior uh in in the
in the evaluation i've made
at this point so i'll present the
version that reduces to bit vectors
um so for first of all to handle
equalities
uh it's handled by union find algorithms
so if we
have a set of character variables
a to t and equality constraints between
those variables
union find will incrementally create
equivalence classes
of those terms and
once a equivalence class contains two
distinct
nodes terms it has
detected a conflict
on the other hand uh character you also
have character constants
uh so in this example e and t are are
constant characters
and um we can perform the same
uh union find and it
also detects conflicts when an
equivalence class contains two
constant characters
that are distinct so this gives a
quick way of of reasoning about
just the pure theory of equalities
now when we use the symbol of of
comparing
bit vector characters the reduction to
bit vectors
is essentially compiling a circuit
for the the bit representation of
characters
so it it there's 18 bits are required to
represent
the domain of u and and now we can
define
a compilation of of less than equal in
two clauses
by by walking the most significant bits
downwards
uh and and so for each uh
sub interval of of comparison
corresponds to
a new propositional variable that's
present it to the sad solver
so now we have two views of theories we
have the equality view
of characters and the blast view of
characters
the um so how can we combine them
so one way of combining them is to
augment now the
the signature with a function that
we can call bridges between the um
theory of of booleans uh and and you
so the um and the uh combinat the way of
combining them is is
for every character that where that gets
bit blasted
introduce an equality that
says that the the bits of a
if you access these 18 bits of a
and convert that to a character you get
a back
and and this allows to
align the quality view with the bitblast
view
and and we only need to do this for
characters that have been bit blasted
but to support this we'll need a
congress closure so
here's an example of using congruence
closure
of on two equalities and
and from these the first two equalities
on the upper left
you can derive that x equals g of x
and the infinite and we require two
inferences
so first we can learn that x equals f of
x
and then from that we can plug in the
solution for
f of x into g of f of x and we get
the last equal equation so to
illustrate how congruence closure works
from a
say high label view every term has a
is given the name so
the f of x is given the name f x if
underscore x
to signify that we treat it as a
as a self-contained constant and now
the equalities that are in originally
introduced
the two equalities create an equivalence
class between
the three of the names and
the fx name is not yet
in in the same equivalence class
but uh the the the the
the task of applying a congress closure
uh will will detect that x and g of f of
x
are both uh arguments of f
and since they're equal in the same
class we also equate
the the nodes representing f of x
and f g of x so we get a new equivalence
class
and when we introduce g of x
we imply apply the same closure
so so this this theory of characters
replaced a theory where
we've reduced it to pure bit vector
reasoning
and and and on average it
uh it gave a 30 speed up or
over uh string uh benchmarks
uh so so that's an example of a say in
choice of encoding that fits a domain
so there's several selected research
areas in the
in in related to bit vectors and
non-interpreted functions
the one level of activities in
word level local search and reducing bit
vector reasoning to
effectively propositional reasoning
and applying computer algebra especially
if your family name starts with k
apparently um then uh
and and their uh developments up so big
open problem is to
solve multipliers efficiently
and and there have been several exciting
developments
around this um
so now uh uh giving a
a quick uh overview of arithmetical
solving
and i won't be able to go into any
details of this but to give an idea of
what goes into solving arithmetical
formulas
it essentially follows a waterfall model
where it first
solves for bounds of variables and then
uses
linear programming relaxation
solve for the bounds it for combinations
of theories
it's useful to propagate equalities
that can be inferred and there's a
challenge of how you infer equalities
efficiently now
when it comes to solving for integers
the several methods based on
branch and bound and cuts in various
forms
and then finally when you have nonlinear
multiplication
you can apply a suite of different
techniques
and these techniques are developed based
on on several
advances in the smt community over the
years
uh given that i uh gave so
much emphasis on on cdclt integration
it's fair to to note that it's not the
only
way you can implement smt solving
so the model constructing sat approach
aims to generalize the cdcl
view to say instead of case baiting on
propositional variables you may as well
case split on the
values of the domain of this course
and finally saturation or yes saturation
methods
uh are
are as legal uh way based but maybe
has not uh shown to be efficiently uh
useful for s and t uh i will go over
one exemplar of the nl set or the mcstat
approach in the context of nonlinear
polynomial arithmetic and the main idea
is to gradually
develop solutions so first we
assign a value to the variable x
your two real variables x and y and
suppose we guess the value
x equals a half and there are uh
three constraints um
four sorry four constraints signified by
the three blue lines and the one
orange line the uh
the uh the constraints are
are feasible they have a green feasible
region but if we choose
x equals a half there's no y that will
hits that feasible region and we can
establish we can prove that there's no y
given the fixed x
by performing a local quantifier
elimination on the
set of constraints that are relevant to
showing that
x doesn't have a feasible extension
so the small core is is the gives a
practical way of
showing showing you that there's a
conflicting no
conflicting clause that there's no
extension of it
and then the quantified elimination
method in the non-linear case is
cylindric
algebraic decomposition
now i'll go through programming as a few
examples on programming with solvers
so first of all you can
the main way of using smt solvers have
been
and remains just finding feasibility so
given a set of constraints is there a
satisfiable solution
you can also show that there's no
solution and
and and solver were both
uninterpreted functions and reals
for more say more
to get it's also possible to get more uh
nuanced information out of solvers and
the main interfaces used here are
to retrieve unsatisfiable cores
even optimized with respect to
objective functions in this example is
max set
so unweighted mac sets you will assign a
set of
soft constraints and then look for
solutions that
violate the minimal set of soft
constraints
or dually satisfy the maximum number of
soft constraints and in applications
related to configuration management
it's uh useful to know what consequences
you have from certain
constraints so if i assume
a and c on the upper right side
side the box uh i'm interested to learn
uh what assignments are
are implied among some set of target
literals
and so consequence finding
and here it's consequence finding with
the explanations
so we can give the set of antecedents
for a certain
consequence as output
gives a way of uh doing configuration
product
management and there's also a recurring
wish list uh specifically uh
counting uh as school bus
emils talk went into detail
about
here is a example of
using the capabilities of
said smt in in
in tandem with more say
advanced uses although this example
are the simplest possible incarnations
of those
more advanced uses so to find
a maximal satisfying
subsets of a set of assumptions
you can start with a candidate model
extracts the true literals from that
model
and then from the literals that were not
assigned true yet you can
then engage in a in the secondary loop
on the lower left side
that attempts to add each lit
unassigned undecided literal
to the partial maximal satisfying
solution
and if it's possible to us
add it then then then you indeed add
that literal and everything else that
was assigned to true and
otherwise if it's not possible to add
that literal
it's it's infeasible and then you can
add it as a backbone
and this mechanism can be used now for
enumerating unsatisfiable cores and
satisfying subsets
and uh there has been several recent
developments in this
uh including the uh um
this the stochastic case that with the
meal and bendic recently
so to finish up some active areas in
smt from from my
narrow view is one is
developing uh proof formats for smt
uh so um so i'm developing a new core
for
for set three and there i'm adapting uh
drop
and drag from the sad world
but to properly support smt requires
several extensions
uh but retaining the the um
the the big value that you can check
proof trails independently when with low
overhead
seems to be a big advantage there are
exciting developments in doing local
search
and integration with the ctcl
and that's useful for um max sats
uh and and finding satisfying
solutions um and we're
looking at uh going beyond array
property fragments
and and so on so that concludes the
uh the the talk
so i think it's time for questions
uh your mic is off bj
thanks nikolai for a nice talk uh
questions please
anybody okay um
i had a couple of questions uh nikolai
so
you mentioned this string
solver in particular the unicode solver
that you had the character solver
and in your experiment you did
you compared
the uh bit vector based solver versus
the
uh conrad's closure and the bit vector
based solver is
surprisingly a bit faster right relative
to
no no it's not it's about 30 40 percent
slower than average slower
okay that makes it not uniformly but but
yeah so so
uh the the um
observation is that uh by performing
this
eager bit blasting when it's rarely
uh useful is just a pure overhead
right that makes sense no yeah so that's
the clarification i wanted
um towards the end of your talk you
talked about programming
with smt and was also the title of your
talk
and the first
kind of thought that comes to mind is
can can you use smt solvers as a way to
just write code i mean you did mention
synthesis
but can i just use it as part of
programming language
and maybe a runtime system so has that
been explored
yes of course it has been explored so
scala
um so
a um version
in in context of scala was was developed
now i believe also
z3 is used in certain constraint logic
programming systems as well
but i guess so the big the
i mean they are um it
it ends up being a question of what
guarantees
you expect of your programming language
uh
so in terms of uh reproducibility or
across uh different variants
so the the the the state
the the solutions you get from a sat
solver
it depends uh heavily on what
starting points you have right
[Music]
so it and and whether you get a solution
or not
the solution stability as well and and i
think it's fair to say that
you can expect the sat solver to give
onset
uh fairly with with fairly low
variance but there's a higher variance
between
satisfiable instances both in time and
then of course in
what what and the instances themselves
and and when the program when you use
the instances in a programming
environment
uh there's a question of uh whether
you're going
whether you expect the same answers
under
uh slight projective perturbations
so yeah basically cracking the knot on
making solver calls stable under
satisfying assignments is is a
long-running challenge in the context of
i think both
smt and then and in extension and sat
in places so
what what what i'm trying these days is
to
learn from the sat world in
in terms of fixing the phase of
variables
during certain stages of search
to skew the cdcl
towards basically what a local search
engine does so this is the second bullet
on this slide
and but otherwise solution stability
also depends has a heavy theory angle
it depends what theories you're of
course yeah moving
and whether you have good solvers so so
spring solver for example is notoriously
unstable
right um
have you have you been using machine
learning methods inside
z3 in recent years
oh so uh i wouldn't say inside
so so we have done one one um
use of of machine learning for um
prioritizing uh so priming the the
variable activity stacks
of cdcl and
and there's a question of uh when when
do you invoke the queries to the machine
learning module
and how do you train the machine
learning
and um so uh kuldip
and matt did for for uh garbage
collection
right so in one variable selection
and you could use you could also use
online methods
as opposed to uh offline training
uh yeah so we we so so i i
i have a mode where cph or chp is used
is available and there's a user who
likes it so
there's there's one of the users who
uh uses all uh all all the randomly
uh parameter settings we expose and he
he says that it's useful for for some
class of
uh any
additional questions anybody
okay so if not thank you nikolai for a
great talk
and our next session will start in about
five minutes
so uh this is a talk by rusicha and her
postdoc i hope i'm
pronouncing his name correctly is it
anon
shy but his former postdoc he's now rock
star at alibaba research
i see yeah all right so let's meet
around
1 30 pm uh est thank you